they went to the mosque for peaceful
contemplation but minutes later dozens
were dared or injured their house of
prayer destroyed it was time for Friday
prayers and everyone had gathered in the
mosque when suddenly a bomb exploded and
many people got hurt one victim says
about 300 people were packed into the
building and rural Husker Manor and
manga ha province when the blast
happened and the roof collapsed onto
those praying below the enemies of
religion and the homeland blew up a
mosque during Friday prayers the Afghan
security forces arrived in the affected
area immediately and help to transport
wounded and remove the dead from the
rubble
there aren't enough ambulances in
Afghanistan so the wounded were lifted
into any car available and rushed to
hospital outside chaos as a steady
stream of vehicles brought in the
injured both the Taliban and ISIL linked
groups are active in the East so the
message that has come from the
government is that it's the Taliban and
it's Taliban Chinese partners who are
responsible for the attack on the other
side we have heard a statement coming
from the Taliban condemning the attack a
Taliban spokesman describing it as a
crime against humanity
the armed groups been engaged in peace
talks with the u.s. in an effort to end
the increasingly brutal 18 year war but
last month President Donald Trump
declared the talks dead blaming a surge
of violence by the Taliban the attack
comes just a day after a UN report said
Afghan civilians were dying in record
numbers Amnesty International says the
blast demands the world's attention but
an anger ha where many now have
life-changing injuries and mass graves
are being dug many filled the
international community's forgotten them
Lexi O'Brien al-jazeera